actress kelly preston has died after a  two-year battle with breast cancer  her husband of nearly 29 years actor  john travolta  broke the sad news to fans on instagram  the couple last starred together in the  2018 film gotti  with travolta playing the late mafia  boss john gotti and preston playing his  wife victoria  preston began her career in the 1980s  and went on to appear in popular movies  like jerry maguire  she is survived by john travolta and two  of their children another son  jett died in 2009 he was 16 at the time  kelly preston was 57 years old and  anthony and tony a lot of us  didn't even know that she was battling  breast cancer which made this story more  of a shock  when we heard the news last night i was  very sad to hear this yeah they didn't  go public with it gail which was like  it was a shock to almost everybody i had  no idea but what we did know publicly is  that they had a very long and loving  marriage nearly 30 years together  yeah celebrate that yes